好 我們來講一下昨天晚上夜盤的操作
那在美股開盤之後的90分鐘內
我在高低震幅只有75點的情況下
90分鐘內刷了超過100點的獲利
也就是說來回刷了超過一倍最高最低的獲利
那我們就來看一下今天的盤是怎麼做的
基本上講完之後大家應該可以完全知道是怎麼做的
然後每個點位的進出理由
然後我在FB也有PO出來
我這一天的每一個進出場的時間是哪個1分K
然後還有進場跟出場的點位
還有全部的對賬單
就是你們要學習的話在FB都是看得到的
好
那我們先簡單的看一下
就是美股開盤是9點半
那9點半之前通常成交量都是比較低的
因為夜盤的走勢是要跟隨美股嘛
那還沒9點半可能會比較不知道接下來的走勢
所以成交量比較低
可以看到3點之後都是沒有打到這個黃線
然後可以先知道一下就是日盤的最高點是16044
然後最低點是15847
那因為夜盤的走勢還是比較有可能會是在16044到15847之間
那當然美股很強很強或很弱的話有可能會突出去
那不過因為如果超過了這個區間的話
例如說突破16044那所有的這個整天的空單都會開始輸錢
那疊破15847的話所有的多單都會開始輸錢
所以最高最低點一定都還是會是多方跟空方的一個防守位置
然後我下午收盤之後我就調鬧鐘睡覺
我就調9點20分的鬧鐘起床
因為9點半才美股開盤嘛
那美股開盤之後才會比較震盪
然後所以我大概是在這個時候起床的
然後就稍微看一下剛有發生什麼事
那看起來剛也沒發生什麼特別的事
然後我們就一根一根1分K看吧
這樣的話大家比較有生利其境的感覺
然後這個地方是美股開盤的第一根1分K
所以可以看到收了一個很長的下影線
那不過這邊還是沒有進場的這個時機
然後OK繼續往下疊了一小段
然後這邊收了一個上下影線
但是也不是有進場的時機
就是不到有轉折
然後到這邊這個是一個100的倍數的關卡嘛
然後疊破到15895
然後下一根分K就馬上站上了
那這個是
這個兩根
就雖然他們沒有到400口
但是他們每個都有到300多口嘛
所以連續起來還是
然後這個又是一個100倍數的百倍關卡
那這個百倍關卡也是一種撐壓嘛
他被疊破之後又站上
所以我就打了一個15902的多單
那這跟我上一次影片的那個904多單是幾乎一樣的對不對
那如果你不知道在講什麼的話可以看一下這個我上一次影片
那我在這邊打了一個15902的多單
那停損的話是多少
這個看過影片大家應該都知道吧
就是破前滴
所以是15894
是停損
好
然後
然後他就順利噴出去了
那這單算是蠻順利的
然後我就在
926的地方
926的地方平常
所以這單是賺了24點
就這樣
902到926
賺了24點
然後
繼續往下看
這一根
是哪一根
這一根是一個突破400口的大量嘛
所以如果
跌破15910的話
我會空單進場
好
然後這邊馬上就
就打到15910了
那這個地方是
你看到這一根紅K
你就開始設定
就是
出現15909
你就出價範圍試價空單進場
那這邊有123456
6根多的一分K可以設
可以慢慢設定嘛
所以
基本上應該是
一定按得到的
就是
不太會
不太會有6分多鐘
還按不到
還按不完成這個出價吧
然後
好
這一根
出價進場
雖然是
這個909空進場
不過
有可能會滑架嘛
這邊是有滑架
是
15908進場
然後
這也都很正常啦
就是909那個Tick被打穿了嘛
然後
這個停損停力怎麼設定
就是
這根
呃
紅K的最高點是
932嘛
所以
是
933到
那
33到
33-09
是
然後呢
然後
呃
所以
他的
呃
Risk
是
多少
24*2
48嘛
然後
我平常在哪裡
好
我平常在
為什麼我可以平常到
好
24*2
我們看一下小算盤
好了
-9
好
沒關係
反正我們就照了算
24嘛
然後
24*2
Risk
是
然後
我是
9-48
好
所以
這時候就直接掛
15861的停力
然後
好
我們就
不要
不要爆雷好了
而且
已經過一個晚上
我也有點忘記了
好
所以我是停力在
要
目標是
停力嘛
然後
這個也是一個
暴打量
所以
這一根
分K
如果被掌過的話
我就會在這邊
呃
高點是
所以
掌過的話
就是
進場
然後
哦
這邊
這邊有一點危險
我想起來
發生什麼事
這邊如果
如果出現
15906的話
我就會
多單進場
然後
把剛剛的
減
除掉
但是
還好沒有達到嘛
所以就表示
這一個
就是
新的
爆打量的
分K的
高低點
都會是
支撐壓力
那這個
壓力算是
守住了
然後
就
哦
就是
這邊就真的很緊張啊
有可能會
但是已經設定好了啦
反正只要出現
906就是
出價
兩倍的多單進場
然後
後來是
沒有發生
啊
然後又出現了
另一個
這個
爆打量的
分K
然後
收了一個
下影線
那
收下影線
之後又長過
這個當然就是
多單進場嘛
所以我這個
這個
綠K的高點是
所以是
這一根
綠K出現
就馬上設定
出價多單進場
然後
啊
就
就長過了嘛
所以
是
把剛剛的
-908
除掉
再
這個
多單進場
對吧
所以我是
其實是
空909
多886
但是
進場
跟出場
各滑架了一點
所以是
變908
然後
同時
進了一個
加
的多單
好
我就先
先不點對
賬單
不然你們會
會被爆雷
會知道
出在哪裡嗎
哦
然後看一下
八八七的多單
應該是怎麼出
八八七
呃
八八六
八八六的多單是
呃
低點是
八六六
對不對
停損是
八六六嘛
如果打到
八六六的話
就
就停損
然後
呃
八八七
好
所以是
二十一點
那
呃
所以
停力
應該是
呃
語言講話有點難那個
呵呵
沒關係
我們就用小算盤
加
二十一乘二
四十二
好
所以是
九二九
九二九的地方會停力
哦
然後
然後我這邊要講的是
因為
我們剛剛記錄了嘛
日盤的最低點是
一五八四七
然後這邊是
從一五八六七往上走
所以是有機會
就是很有可能可以直接
有一個一百點的
往上的行情的
í呢
我在
剛剛算的這個
呃
一五九二九的位置
我只會
停力出掉一半
然後
另外一半的話
我會掛在
一百點之外
停力
也就是在
一五九八七的地方
停力
然後
所以
第一停力點是
呃
九二九
第二停力點是
九八七
然後
哎
哦
這根
這根就到了
這根的高點是
九三零嘛
所以
這邊
九二九第一停力點就到了
然後就
出掉了一半
哦
然後
值得注意的是
這一根本身也是
超過四百口的爆打量
那
所以
在下一根
他被疊破
我就
這個
空單進場
就是把
剛才的另外一半
平倉掉
加上
空單進場
那
例如說你原本是
呃
三口
呃不對
三三是
三是
不是二的倍數
兩口小台好了
那
兩口小台
在
這個
929的地方
你會設定出掉一口
然後
987的地方
你會
設定
出另外一口嘛
但是因為這個是一個四百口的大量
所以你在這邊會
再另外設定
如果
出現了
呃
919被疊破的918
你就
呃
三口的空單進場
因為你要把剛剛的一口多單出掉
然後再
再打兩口的空單
我不知道大家聽不聽得懂
這個應該
聽不懂
反正是影片嘛
你可以回去再重看一次
好
然後再下一根就疊破了
所以呢
剛才的這個
加887的多單呢
會
有一半出在
這個
然後另外一半
會出在
這個應該也沒有很複雜
對不對
好
所以呢
有一半會出在929
另一半出在918
那
927的話是因為
就是會滑價嘛
這個滑價的是
就是交易本來就會滑價
你在那個地方
出現了
929的時候
就是
呃
出價打了一個空單
奇怪
為什麼我不是用掛的
感覺用掛的話
應該不會滑價
還是那時候我算錯了
所以
好
反正
反正這個是左邊出場停地嘛
我其實掛929
跟掛927差不多
應該是那時候我算錯了
我猜是因為我把Risk算成20
所以
所以我是887加
兩倍
變成927
因為
停地是預掛
所以停地是不會滑價的
好那就是我算錯了
那少賺兩點
就是
不過也是剛好高點是930啦
如果高點是928的話就被我賺到
好不過這個應該是我算錯的
應該
應該掛929是不會滑價的
然後
好不過也差不多啦
差不了多少
就是
反正停地掛遠一點是比較好的
那我少掛兩點這個
也還好啦
然後發生什麼事呢
然後
然後這個是一個918的空單嘛
那918的空單
高點是
所以
是
它的Risk是
931-918
918還919
他Risk是
13嘛
然後13乘以2是
那所以
它的停地點是
918-26
所以是
892停地
然後呢
然後在這個地方就停順了
這個地方
尖尖的突出去一個
碰到了
這個
那
我就出價停順了
所以這邊這一個
這個
這一小根就是
我就在裡面
所以呢
這個是
空
然後
所以這個停順13點
然後呢
然後又出現了一根
超過
超過400口的
紅K嘛
然後再下
再下下根就跌破了
那這個
這個紅K的低點是
高點是
所以是
923到
我是
出價
進場空單
然後
高點是
942嘛
所以是
943停順
所以Risk是
943到
那
所以我就要在
呃
Risk
的兩倍
地方停領
扣掉
所以是
多少
停順
然後
這根其實下面就有883
這個
10.56
然後
我是在10.56就已經停順到了
因為在夜盤的時候啊
那個
委託的掛單
有非常
大部分都是
AI在那邊掛
然後他們的掛
尾賣尾賣是會
一直在那邊跳來跳去跳來跳去的
所以你在這個地方
先進場
進場的時候就直接掛883停順的話
你排隊會在那些跳來跳去的AI單前面
不過其實
台子騎排隊不是很重要啦
就是那種出價沒有成交也不是很常發生
好
然後
那反正我有回去看成交明細
我是在
10.56這根就已經
達到了
那
這邊又是低點883
那如果
剛好
就是這樣點到點到
然後就往上的話
那我就會蠻幸運的
好
不過
當然後來是有更低點了
好
然後
然後我們就直接把這個
縮小給大家看嘛
就是
那後面就一直
成交量就沒有再打到這條黃線
然後就一直到
到凌晨4點每股收盤
都沒有達到
那當然4點後通常也都不太會再出現
這樣這麼大的爆大量了
所以
就是這樣
哇
直接噴到後面去了
好
這就是
今天的操作
那
可以看到
就是
好還算是蠻順利的
最高最低點
只有75點的
政府
然後
卻打出了
超過100點的獲利
那
就這樣
就是
點數就是這樣
然後最後
獲利是102.5點
然後最後一單的
最後一單是
918摸了一個頭
然後
就是
被停損
然後又再
923重新進場
然後
就
又再賺了一個40點
然後
就
講過很多次嘛
就不要因為
啊
913後來
後來913出掉又923重新進場
所以913就不停損
因為是有可能一路噴出去嘛
就是該停損就是要停損
然後
要轉折了
再進場
不要
就是沒有轉折
就直接掛一個點位在那邊
然後直接被
被一大根穿過去
然後輸很多錢
好
這些都有講過很多次
感覺
今天這個操作好像
蠻簡單的對吧
看起來
大家應該都做得到
哎呦很困難
啊
就是
一個半小時賺100點
就是這麼簡單
打了5單
好
就這樣啦
這就是今天的副把安
希望大家都學到很多東西
拜拜